During a roundtable discussion with the podcast
Skytalkers, Jon Favreau made some interesting
comments that indicated Grogu and The Mandalorian
had been traveling together for years before
the finale of Season 2.
It's also implied Grogu spent years in Jedi
training with Luke Skywalker before returning
to Din Djarin.
Favreau explained:
"He started off earlier in the Jedi temple
... and then we know that he's been rescued
and spent many years with The Mandalorian.
Went back with Luke.
Now, we've been two years apart from him there,
training."
Favreau's comments imply that all of "The
Mandalorian" Season 1 and 2 takes place over
"many years," which is not directly addressed
in the show.
It also implies the time jump between Season
2 and "The Book of Boba Fett" is two years long.
While the exact timeline of "The Mandalorian"
remains unclear, Favreau's use of "many years"
certainly makes it seem like Grogu and Din
Djarin spent more time together than actually
seen in "The Mandalorian."
What kinds of adventures have we missed?